we can't get enough of disney princess  makeovers  want to see your favorite ladies in a  whole new light take a look at talented  illustrator rafaela tuma's tick-tock  transformations  guess which princesses glow-up gives us  varsity vibes  and which lady rocks serious library  chic  from their blunt cuts and dye jobs to  their faux freckles and stacked sneakers  they're all now thoroughly modern  princesses you'll love their makeovers  just as much as we do  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  which disney princesses makeover made  you want to copy her style the most  be sure to tell us in the comments  section and hit that subscribe button  for  instant notifications when we upload our  next videos  thanks for watching  you